führt das mit unserem land ja und über
dieses thema möchte ich sprechen mit
meinen gästen dem spd
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach dem
cdu generalsekretär markus blume der fdp
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin
bettina stark watzinger und der
cdu-politikerin jana schimke herr blume
wir haben heute ein neues wort gelernt
brücken lockdown das ist das was armin
laschet jetzt ins gespräch gebracht hat
nach loch downlight wellenbrecher
lockdown allen möglichen lockdown es
jetzt der brücken lockdown macht das
sinn was armin laschet da vorhin gesagt
hat und macht es vor allem sinn
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt
auf diese woche vorzuziehen
na gut ich glaube entscheiden bei der
korona bekämpfung ist dass wir etwas
machen was wirkt und wo auch ein ganz
klarer kurs erkennbar ist eine neue mpk
alleine bringt ja noch nichts wenn
danach wie wir jeder seins macht
deswegen ist ganz entscheidend dass die
bereitschaft der länder da ist ich sage
übrigens auch der cdu regierten länder
dass man eine mpk vorzieht und dass man
dann auch bereit ist zu weitergehenden
maßnahmen ich bin mir moment nicht
sicher ob das wirklich bei allen ländern
der fall ist
ich höre da aus einzelnen ländern oder
sehe auch dass dort eher zum teil der
andere weg gegangen ist man manch einer
möchte sein ganzes land zu einer
modellregion erklären also da glaube ich
es noch etwas überzeugungsarbeit
tatsächlich notwendig sind sie denn in
bayern dafür dass diese mpk stattfindet
denn markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident derzeit sichert zum
sogenannten team vorsicht also müsste er
doch dafür seien jetzt ein bundesland
daun einen brückenlauf down oder was
auch immer
schärferes umzusetzen markus söder hatte
das am sonntag ja auch noch mal deutlich
gemacht er erst dafür dass wir alles tun
möglichst schnell eine situation zu
erreichen wo auch das impfen dann mehr
wirkt es wirkt umso mehr je niedriger
die inzidenz ist deswegen sind zwei
dinge für uns entscheidend erstens der
vereinbarte die vereinbarte notbremse
sie muss überall konsequent umgesetzt
werden und zweitens alles was hilft
nämlich kurz und konsequent die zahlen
deutlich nach unten zu bringen und eine
drohende überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
das wäre gut aber nochmal ein crooner
lockdown herum wer wie wir das bei der
letzten mpk erlebt haben
mit stundenlangen sitzungen und danach
geht wieder auseinander macht
unterschiedlich ist das kann nicht wahr
sein wie kann das sind auch ihre reiter
dass man auch in diese richtung
unterwegs sind
aber wie kann es denn aus ihrer sicht
funktionieren sie wollen ja diesen
bundesweit einheitliche noch da und
diesem bundesweit einheitlichen plan
wie kann er funktionieren aus ihrer
sicht ich glaube dass sich sowohl die
regierung als auch die b regierten
länder also die spd regierten und die
unionsregierten länder zunächst einmal
klar werden müssen sind wir auch
gemeinschaftlich dazu bereit
wie aus bayern heraus wir von seiten der
csu wir sagen jawohl wir sind bereit
diesen weg zu gehen wenn es notwendig
ist auch weitergehende maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
man muss allerdings heute am ostermontag
auch folgen wir sagen wir haben im
moment kein ganz klares lagebild was die
zahlen angeht über die feiertage sind
die zahlen verzerrt
das heißt wir wissen nicht genau was
eigentlich jetzt moment tatsächlich an
der infektions front passiert und nur
ganz kurz sehen sie das auch so
gefährlich wie ich dass diese zahlen
immer noch nicht ein jahr nach der
pandemie an nach feiertagen geordnet
sind und nach sonntagen wie kann das
sein
ich glaube da kommen verschiedene dinge
zusammen die menschliche natur am
feiertag wenn es nicht so gut geht geht
man vielleicht nicht gleich zum arzt wie
unter der woche und dann möglicherweise
in einzelnen regionen ländern
landkreisen auch die situation dass da
nicht jeder ofen hat nicht jeder so
schnell meldet das sind die dinge die
offensichtlich auch nach einem jahr
pandemie noch zu unschärfe dazugehören
wollen uns einmal anschauen was armin
laschet heute nachmittag spontan muss
man sagen geäußert hat deshalb glaube
ich brauchen wir einen brücken lockdown
wir müssen die brücke hin zu dem
zeitpunkt wo viele menschen geimpft sind
noch einmal bauen was kann das konkret
sein
wir brauchen weiterhin weniger private
kontakte das kann auch ausgangs
beschränkungen in den abend und
nachtstunden bedeuten wir müssen uns
fokussieren auf das notwendige bei kita
und schule wir müssen mehr machen beim
home office es sind immer noch viel zu
viele menschen in bewegung zum
arbeitsplatz in diesen zwei drei wochen
muss die home office offensive der
deutschen wirtschaft noch mal
vorankommen
die bundesregierung wird in dieser woche
mit den wirtschaftsverbänden auch über
die testungen in den betrieben sprechen
es muss bei der schließung der
gastronomie bleiben und wir müssen im
gesamten bereich der freizeitgestaltung
noch einmal eine reduktion erreichen
lauterbach brücken lockdown mpk
vorziehen aus der spd hört man in diesen
stunden dass man das nicht so toll fand
was armin laschet da gesagt hat wie
sehen sie das
na ja zunächst einmal also der begriff
brücken doch daran dass man sich sehr
gut weil er trifft es ja ganz genau wir
müssen nochmal eine brücke geschlagen
bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo wir die
hochrisiko leute alle geimpft haben und
die dritte welle muss hier quasi noch
einmal niedergerungen werden
somit ist der begriff auf jeden fall
richtig und zu zeigen dass man sich
relativ früh jetzt gedanken macht dazu
was zu tun ist das halte ich auch für
richtig auch bestimmen somit was muss da
auch klar sein was da rauskommt nur die
instrumente sind alle da also quasi kann
jetzt das wissenschaftlich als gesichert
gelten was wir machen müssten wir müssen
halt sehr intensiv also investieren in
die vorbereitung der schule dass schule
nur stattfinden wenn wechsel
unterrichtet und zwar wie lange sollte
der locker und sein herr lauterbach bis
ende des monats wie lange stellen sie
sich das vor
also das konto
produktionswert der zeigt wie viele
leute stecken sich an bei jedem der
schon angesteckt ist der muss stabil
unter 1 sein und wenn man das
sonderzahlung erreicht hat und man hat
sinkende zahlen dann also ist doch dann
wieder aufzuhören so lange lassen wir
nicht kurz die maßnahmen ist der sommer
zuschauer hat ja nichts davon
zuerst war so beschrieben wird wie lange
geht es um dann was überhaupt gemacht
werden sollen also ich wusste dass
sozusagen erstmal erklären können was
man machen könnte und dann stellen wir
uns die frage wie lange soll es wirken
weil sonst ist ja die frage wie lange
sowas wirken und ich würde so ein
stärken indem ich also die also in der
schule noch mal diesen test nicht alle 2
also zwar noch pro woche einführen
wechsel unterricht an ist muss deutlich
werden den betrieben gemacht werden
dort muss auch textlich und homeoffice
nicht kommen und daneben eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
ein moratorium für alle neuerungen an
das hat natürlich keinen sinn wenn wir
es gleichzeitig mit lockerungsübungen
mit lockerungs modellen kaputtmachen
wenn man das zwei oder drei wochen
durchhalten würde könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass in zwei drei wochen
tatsächlich die fahrzeit instabil
wiedersehen können aber das aber karl
lauterbach ganz kurz weil da sind zwei
drei wochen werden immer wieder genannt
wenn es neuen locker und gab ich
erinnere mich an die runde als kneipen
restaurants dichtgemacht wurde da wurde
gesagt na ja ein paar wochen dann können
wir weihnachten feiern so ähnlich ging
das weiter wer soll ihnen das noch
glauben in der politik egal welcher
partei wenn sie jetzt sagen zwei bis
drei wochen dann klappt es zunächst
haben wir also es ist anders gemacht
worden ist
märz wird in den restaurants zugemacht
haben beim sogenannten wellenbrecher
locker da ist genau das passiert was wir
jetzt auch wieder nach dem kaum hatten
wir es besprochen haben die
ministerpräsidenten den ausnahmen
angekündigt und haben die nachrichten
müssen den leuten gehen kaputt gemachte
lockerungen damals der black friday
es wurde sogar über verkaufsoffene
sonntage gesprochen glühweinstände alles
mit was sowie kann uns das ganze sparen
werden wir in einen doktor gehen
gleichzeitig auch lockerungen aber
sicher dass das ganze so sagen weil also
wer soll uns doch glauben
das kommt einfach davor darauf an ob wir
dann auch konsequent sind werden dann
quasi diesen london macht wir sind auch
so von mir aus bücken oder was auch
immer
wenn man den zwei drei wochen war dann
muss klar sein das sind nur zwei oder
drei wochen dann wenn der erbe doch
runter geht wie eben beschrieben sonst
wird es länger das wasser dort sagen und
das ganze hat wirklich nur zwecks uns
kann man sich das ganze sparen
das hat nur zweck wenn das gleichzeitig
mit einem moratorium für lockerungen an
ihr geht wenn ich gleichzeitig ganze
bundesländer also öffne oder wenn nicht
locken
aber das ist ja schon klar jetzt oder
wie man das nicht funktionieren wird
weil einzelne länder bereits gesagt
haben sie machen da nicht mit zum
beispiel dann günther der
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
und hat gesagt ausgangssperren mit mir
nicht ja wenn das so ist dann also nutzt
auf ein solches treffen ist also wenn es
tatsächlich vorher schon festlegung geht
wir machen die maßnahmen nicht die wir
brauchen
dann also wird das nicht funktionieren
dann nutzer braucht darauf hinauslaufen
dass die fahrt zahl wie das sehr stark
steigen werden dann kommen wir in eine
massive dritte welle wir verlieren nur
zahlt und das würde später doch machen
müssen
das geht einfach nicht von alleine weg
und wir halten das nicht aus bis er
genug leute geimpft werden
sein also man muss es ganz klar sagen
man kann eine dritte welle weder weg
testen noch kann man sie weg ist eine
solche welle zu stark vor schimke wie
haben sie heute den auftritt ihres
parteichefs erlebt und was denken sie
ist jetzt nötig also ich war schon etwas
irritiert das gebe ich zu ich bleibe
dabei ich bin ein verfechter auch von
lokalen projekten und ich bin weit davon
entfernt zu sagen dass die
ministerpräsidenten hier etwas kaputt
machen ich glaube das sind leute die
sind wirklich noch nahe bei den menschen
vor ort die haben gut
das gespür dafür was machbar ist und was
auch wirkt und ich bin froh darüber dass
wir in einem freien land leben in dem es
auch noch sonderwege gibt und die auch
zugelassen werden und insofern bin ich
dafür weiterhin auch diesen kurs zu
fahren lokal zu schauen wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen und dann auch darauf
zu reagieren wenn wir nach einem jahr
corona immer noch über auf und zu reden
auf und zumachen und ist das einzige ist
was wir als antwort den menschen
anzubieten haben dann glaube ich ist mit
einer erkenntnis nicht sehr weit
gekommen
es geht doch nicht um die frage ob dir
eindhoven sondern die hier einkaufen ja
wie wir leben und wie man das möglich
machen kann und ich glaube das geht nur
wenn wir müssen schneller werden aber
wenn wir auch eine gute strategie haben
ich glaube wir sind ja bisher auch einen
guten weg gewesen
wie erklären sie sich dass sie sagen sie
sind irritiert darüber gewesen wie sich
armin laschet der cdu-chef und
nrw-ministerpräsident heute geäußert hat
wie erklären sie sich das denn er war
vor einem jahr oder sagen wir
dreivierteljahr einer derjenigen der
ganz bewusst vor allem für eine öffnung
strategie geworben hatte und immer davor
gewarnt hat dass der lockdown eben nicht
das einzige mittel sein darf warum macht
er das jetzt in das taktische gründe
weil er sozusagen wieder auf der seite
von kanzlerin merkel spielen will um der
bessere karten für den für die mögliche
kanzlerkandidatur zu haben also herr uns
immer das ist jetzt im raum des
spekulativen ich hab im ami laschet
immer sehr dafür geschätzt dass er da
auch andere wege geht in nordrhein
westfalen in einem so großen bundesland
wo es auch nicht einfach ist öko ohne
einzudämmen
und insofern ich kann ihnen die frage
nicht beantworten ich weiß nicht was ihn
motiviert aber was ist was hat sie dann
genau irritiert was hat sie genau
irritiert der kurswechsel hat mich
irritiert weil ich denke schon dass auch
unsere ministerpräsidenten unsere
landesregierungen sich sehr genau
überlegen welchen weg sie gehen doch um
sie diesen weg gehen und wenn man diesen
weg dann verlässt und zwar radikal
verlässt und sozusagen eine ganz andere
richtung einschlägt dann ist das etwas
was glaubwürdigkeit nicht unbedingt
fördert und insofern war ich doch heute
etwas irritiert das gebe ich zu was
meinen sie im namen kurz bei dem thema
zu bleiben bei dem mit diesem
kurswechsel meinen sie dass er sozusagen
auch wieder in richtung schulen
schließen
möchte das ist jetzt um ausgangs
beschränkungen danach geht was konkret
ist für sie da der der kurswechsel war
gefühlt sind wir seit wochen und monaten
in diesem lockdown januar die
kommunikation war seitens seiner person
bisher immer gewesen zu sagen zu schauen
was möglich ist zuversicht zu geben
hoffnung zu geben
und wenn man jetzt wieder mit einer
botschaft nach draußen geht die glaube
ich nicht so spontan war denn sie stand
ja auch dem zob in dem beitrag gesehen
haben dann hat er sich da sicherlich
auch was dabei gedacht warum er jetzt
die da zu machen will und sozusagen die
andere linie vertritt und das bin ich
persönlich sehr schade vor stark
watzinger bei der fdp haben sie in den
letzten monaten den kurs gehabt zu sagen
das was die regierung macht funktioniert
so nicht mehr
dieser lockdown funktioniert so nicht
mehr was tun sie wenn jetzt tatsächlich
dieser bundes lockdown brücken lockdown
oder wie auch immer geartet kommt und
tatsächlich wieder eine dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
also ich fange mit dem positiven an was
ich heute gehört habe und das ist dass
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt
einmal füße stattfinden soll man also an
einen tisch sitzt das mindert dann
vielleicht auch das risiko dass einige
ministerpräsidenten candy crash spielen
ich sage das nur deshalb nicht ausnehme
sondern weil einfach das vertrauen in
die entscheidung und das entscheidung
vom ende her gedacht werden
doch verloren gegangen ist jetzt haben
den begriff brücken lockdown gehört aber
ein neues wort ist leider noch kein
neues konzept und wir sehen leider
lieder dass die vorschläge sich sehr
stark darauf konzentrieren im privaten
bereich nochmals nachzuschärfen ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass ich klare
forderungen gehört hätte wie wir jetzt
den impfstoff schneller beschaffen ich
hätte mir gewünscht klare forderungen
wir pragmatischer bei der impfkampagne
sehen wie ihr sie entbürokratisieren
können wir schaffen das im stoff nicht
verfällt weil eben die termine nicht
wahrgenommen werden all das wären gute
wege gewesen und vertrauen in die
politik aber auch schnelligkeit in die
kampagne zu
ringen also ein team vorsicht hätte herr
laschet ein team tempo endsieg
entgegensetzen können wir werden weiter
darauf drängen dass im parlament
diskutiert wird
denn einige der entscheidung die jetzt
wieder im raum stehen wie zb die
nächtliche ausgangssperre
die sind ja unverhältnismäßig die
freiheitseinschränkung ist
unverhältnismäßig zu dem was an wirklich
an effizienz der maßnahme ist also wir
wissen ja dass nur ein ganz kleiner
bruchteil zwischen 22 uhr und 5 uhr
morgens um sieben prozent mobilität in
unserem land dass es unverhältnismäßig
jede maßnahme muss verhältnismäßig sein
das muss im parlament diskutiert werden
dann gäbe es bessere entscheidung war
sie hat schon gesagt das kommt ja nicht
darauf an ob wir einkaufen gehen sondern
wie viele kontakte wir haben welches
risiko ist und deswegen kann man den
menschen einiges zumuten in einer
pandemie aber man muss auch die kritik
aushalten muss es breites boot ihren
deswegen werden wir noch mal unsere
forderungen ergeben dass die kanzlerin
vor der mpk im bundestag informiert
stichwort mpk herr blume da gab es in
den vergangenen tagen wochen ja große
diskussion ob es in wahrheit ein
bundesgesetz brauche auch die kanzlerin
hat das ins spiel gebracht und wenn man
jetzt hört das ist widerstand ja auch
von ihnen offenbar gegen eine mpk in
dieser woche gibt gehen sie davon aus
dass die kanzlerin am ende sagen wird
man muss das infektionsschutzgesetz so
ändern dass der bund noch größere
durchgriffsrechte bekommt wäre das
sinnvoll aus ihrer sicht das vielleicht
zunächst mal der wonsheimer es gibt
keinen widerstand
aber klar ist doch eine mpk anzusetzen
macht nur sinn wenn man absehbarer weise
vermuten kann das dann auch etwas
rauskommt und alleine jetzt in unserer
sendung gehört man es geht in völlig
unterschiedliche richtungen ist es von
allen seiten auch noch mal gesagt worden
die instrumente ist sie liegen
eigentlich alle auf dem tisch jedes land
könnte so konsequent sein wie es nur
irgend geht aber trotzdem haben viele
ministerpräsidenten dann andere
absichten und fahren einen anderen kurs
und solange es da nicht möglich ist sich
zu verständigen hilft die beste mpk
nichts da kann man noch zehn stunden
tragen dh
es braucht im vorfeld ein übereinkommen
es muss eine braucht eine übereinkunft
es braucht eine bereitschaft auch in den
parteien sowohl bei den spd geführten
ländern wie auch bei den unionsgeführten
ländern zu sagen jawohl die lage ist so
wir haben eine gemeinsame
lagebeurteilung und wir stehen jetzt vor
der wahl wollen wir einen dauer lockdown
mit einer dauerwelle nämlich einer
dritten welle die dann irgendwann bis in
den juni juli hinein geht aber halt eben
nichts halbes und nichts ganzes oder
wollen auf der anderen seite noch mal
konsequenter sein
nochmal eine extra portion disziplin
aufbringen die kontakte deutlich
reduzieren aber auch der bürger
herauszuholen wenn sie extra portion
disziplin sagen die menschen das merkt
man doch sind corona müde und vor allem
sind sie müde von denen was politiker
ihnen den vergangenen monaten
versprochen haben können sie da sind sie
überhaupt noch imstande disziplin
einzufordern
nein es geht nicht um einfordern sondern
es geht darum deutlich zu machen was am
ende hilft ffp 28 und pflicht zum
beispiel wäre ein thema da wäre noch
einmal viel gewonnen ist immer noch
nicht überall der fall und so gibt es
viele weitere dinge der lauterbach hat
einige davon genannt also wir haben
alles von dem wir wissen dass es helfen
kann uns ist kontakt kommt am ende nur
auf die konsequenz in der umsetzung an
die bevölkerung hat super mitgemacht
also man muss schon den richtigen
adressaten hier ansprechen die
bevölkerung hat super mitgemacht aber es
braucht auch die richtigen vorgaben die
richtigen leitplanken und das ist das
was von der nächsten zusammenkunft der
ministerpräsidenten dann auch
tatsächlich ausgehen muss also sollte
die kanzlerin am besten die länder
entmachten und den bund durch ziehen
herr blumen also ein solches
bundesgesetz wäre sicherlich eine
möglichkeit
dann wäre übrigens auch die
parlamentarische beteiligung gesichert
die vielfach immer extra eingefordert
wurde allerdings mit blick auf die
gesetzgebungsverfahren müssen wir auch
das kann natürlich auch seine zeit
dauern
ich wünsche mir einfach die gemeinsame
einsicht der ministerpräsidenten
zusammen mit der bundeskanzlerin dass
wir jetzt noch mal eine besondere
herausforderungen
drei vier wochen zu meistern haben und
wir stehen jetzt vor der wahl geben wir
es machen wir es noch mal extra gut oder
bringen wir es nicht zu sammeln und wenn
wir es nicht zusammenbringen dann wird's
erst besserung geben wenn wir dann
wirklich in ganz großem umfang durch
geimpft sind
das eigentliche signal der hoffnung
haben wir gerade das osterfest hinter
uns das eigentliche signal der hoffnung
ist ja dass in den zweiten quartal 70
millionen impfdosen nach deutschland
kommen und das heißt am ende des zweiten
quartals da wird die welt dann schon
eine andere sein aber wir werden umso
besser dastehen je niedriger wir von der
intelligenz her jetzt durch dieses
zweite quartal gehen
herr lauterbach aus ihrer sicht wenn sie
sich anschauen wie sich da einzelne
ministerpräsidenten jetzt schon wieder
geäußert haben kann man nicht davon
ausgehen dass es da eine einheitliche
linie geben wird oder wie was erwarten
sie
wie das ganze jetzt entschieden wird und
halten sie ein bundesgesetz das ja die
kanzlerin bereits angesprochen hatte für
sinnvoll
ja zunächst einmal lassen sie mich noch
einen satz sagen zu dem was mit
wahnsinniger wir sind stark watzinger
gesagt wurde also dass wir ihn sichtbar
das ist sehr wichtig dass die menschen
das verstehen auch zum schutz derjenigen
denen im zentrum arbeiten die
impfzentren und auch die aussicht sich
jetzt beteiligen da ist eine
erstklassige arbeit es bleibt kein
impfstoff gegen das wird so schnell ist
wie dies möglich ist der begrenzende
faktor ist einfach da nicht vor allem
eben stoff das liegt nicht daran ist
eine bürokratie im spiel während die
leute sind dort wirklich hoch motiviert
es wird nichts weggeschmissen und es
wird wirklich mit hochdruck das eine
großartige leistung die da abgerufen
wird und die dort und nicht immer den
völlig falschen eindruck erwecken als
wenn das ebenso effizient in deutschland
wäre es fehlt eben stoff das hat die eu
zu vertreten aber das ist nicht die auch
das ist nicht die schuld der menschen
den weg zum arbeiten aber ich glaube
auch nicht dass das jemand glaubt dass
die schulter menschen mit impfzentren
sondern ist klar wir sind nicht nur die
eu sondern eben auch politiker hier in
deutschland die sich ihren der
gesundheitsminister die das sofa
nordenham und handeln das ist wichtig
zu sehen dass klar bei der eindruck darf
nicht entstehen dass langsamer gehen
würde als geimpft werden könnte sondern
dass immer nicht 24 stunden wie die
bundeswehr jetzt gemacht hat man könnte
weil ich nicht weil ich nicht mehr
greife nicht für 24 stunden dem stoff
habe ich habe einfach also wer die 15
sonne arbeiten längst nicht auf der
vollen kapazität können zum beispiel
doppelt dreimal soviel impfen werden
auch dass wir jederzeit bereit auch die
18 wären da wir haben einfach nicht den
impfstoff also werden wir also rund um
die uhr irgendwann ich hab doch nichts
wenn ich nur impfstoffe schnell es in 56
stunden habe das ja nicht verstehst du
es ist einfach es bleibt nichts leben es
geht wirklich so schnell in den namen
geht die zahl der stunden spielt keine
rolle
das ging ja nicht schneller wir haben
einfach nicht genug gesagt dass nur
deshalb weil ich mit fehlen bisher in
die zentren in kontakt stehe und den
stets wirklich zum hals wenn sie ständig
die ratschläge bekommen seite ein
bisschen weniger bürokratisch ist
schneller
es kann ich kann nicht schneller impfen
als ich impfstoff habe das ist wichtig
wenn sie über bürokratie sprechen was
ist jetzt ja was ist der schnellste weg
um gesetze zu machen die aus sicht der
kanzlerin zumindest oder aus sicht
einzelner ministerpräsidenten notwendig
wären wobei ist daran die auch viel
kritik gibt genau ich glaube dass ein
bundesgesetz zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
keinen sinn machen würde weil wir haben
schon wieder das gleiche problem was wie
oft und ich sprechen dann über politik
aus sowieso politik ist funktionieren
wer hat welchen einfluss welche macht
stadtpolitik zu machen
der blume hat ja recht auch so ich
stimme eben dazu in der gleichen lage
wir haben die instrumente was soll's wir
müssen uns einfach im vorfeld einigen
wir wollen die instrument auch einsetzen
und wenn wir die einsetzen wollen dann
müssen wir nichts neues erfinden er
finde das ist ein ambulatorium für
öffnung also noch eine kreisrunde wie
beim letzten mal mit 29 ruhe in reihen
wenn man sich vorher einig dass man
tatsächlich da übereinkommen will dann
macht das durchaus sinn und wir werden
sowieso dazu kommen dann wenn es nichts
zu hören
die probleme gehen
nicht weg der hat was viele menschen
denken was aber falsch ist man kann dass
man die idee wenn wir jetzt nur noch
etwas länger impfen oder etwas mehr
testen dann geht es auch von alleine weg
das ist eben nicht so das reicht nicht
ich komme nicht über die runden mit
impfen und testen allein sondern so
haben wir das jetzt klingt aber ich muss
tatsächlich die ausgangs beschränkung
machen ich muss die home office pflicht
durchsetzen ich muss den tests zwang in
schulen und in den betrieben durchsetzen
und ich muss auch das harte moratorium
für öffnungen habe ich das nicht mache
ist der locker und zu schwach dann
dauerte länger und lauter was sie sagen
man muss das machen
es gibt dazu unterschiedliche meinungen
unter anderem gab es aussagen vom chef
der krankenhausgesellschaft von herrn
gas und da haben wir ein zitat vorliegen
er hat nämlich gesagt dass keine
überlastung der intensivstation droht
jeder schwerkranke egal ob kur wird oder
nicht wird eine angemessene versorgung
in den kliniken erhalten eine totale
überlastung unseres gesundheitssystems
oder gar triage wird es in den kommenden
wochen absehbar nicht geben
herr lauterbach warum brauchen wir dann
härtere maßnahmen ja weil ich nicht
wollen dass zu viele menschen dauerhaft
krank werden oder aber moment dass das
das war doch immer das argument für
harte maßnahmen dass man gesagt hat man
muss die überlastung der
intensivstationen abwenden aber es nicht
das alleinige dass ich vorher uns aber
wir hätten jetzt plötzlich durch ein
wunder helfen wir 300.000 intensivbetten
dann wird doch kein normaler noch bei
verstand wäre sagen okay ich füllen wir
jetzt alle mit gobi patient man können
wir uns mehr corvette patienten lasten
natürlich könnt ihr dann alle versorgt
werden aber die hälfte der war aber ich
halte es für problematisch ehrlich
gesagt dass das ursprungs argument was
ja auch mal von ihnen kamen und anderen
politikern kam dass eben die
intensivstation unter keinen umständen
überlastet werden können jetzt
ausgehebelt wird und gesagt wird na ja
das sei doch nicht das einzige argument
und man muss erstmal die position von
herrn gas den ich sehr schätze
also das ist ja gar nachts aber die
intensivmediziner die das geschäft
machen der karagiannis oder marx ja mit
der markt gestern nicht noch einmal
ausgebaut
wir sehen das anders sie sehen also die
bedrohung hier sehr klar und auch sie
sagen wir werden noch sehr kurzer zeit
werden wir massiv überlastet sein und
können das nicht mehr darstellen auf dem
niveau was wir haben wollen
also wir sprechen da ganz klar die
praktiker also die leute die sozusagen
diese arbeit machen
wir haben alle die allergrößten not und
ich sagen wir müssen jetzt unbedingt in
aktion treten weil werden sonst in drei
vier wochen werden die überlaufen der
gast ich das anders aber ich will nur
sagen die leute an der front leute an
der basis
karl ott marc skokanitsch wir sind den
engen austausch hier haben wir auch
öffentlich gesagt das ist so nicht aber
das hat ja durchaus einen überblick über
das frau schimke um sie dann noch mal
mit reinzuholen wie sehen sie das wenn
da jetzt der chef der
krankenhausgesellschaft sagt naja es
droht keine überlastung wie bringt man
den menschen dann erklären dass man
jetzt auch noch ausgangssperren braucht
das man noch radikalere massnahmen
braucht also zunächst einmal vertraulich
experten gehören gas mehr als den
kollegen der spd die möglicherweise
versuchen hier ihre partei programmatik
durch die hintertür durchzusetzen
home office pflicht und was wir da alles
führen so ist meine auffassung satz ja
das heißt halten sie auch aus diesem
grund schärfere maßnahmen für nicht
notwendig wenn so ein experte sagt es
gibt eben keine überlastung
das ist ja die grundsatzfrage
wie jetzt schärfere maßnahmen brauchen
oder nicht was ich feststelle ist dass
man bis heute nicht wirklich weiß oder
vermutet wo das infektionsgeschehen her
kommt nämlich aus dem privaten raum und
dann zu sagen wir müssen jetzt bei den
bei den betrieben für eine home office
pflicht sorgen wo jetzt schon die
meisten beschäftigten die es können im
home office sind ja und auch noch am
besten eine gesetzliche tests pflicht
einführen ohne zu wissen wo überhaupt
die tests herkommen soll und wer das
alles bezahlen soll
das ist etwas was vertrauen nicht gerade
fördert bei den menschen und ich glaube
das ist er sehr wichtig jetzt gerade in
dieser zeit
der mann dagegen hatte ich möchte
ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen das was
ich hier vortage hat nichts mit
parteipolitik zu tun und wird so auch
von anderen wissenschaftlern auch von
anderen wissenschaftlern gefordert also
die home office pflicht und auch die
also verpflichtende testung in den
betrieben dass notmaßnahme von führenden
wissenschaftlern auch dass christian
osten ist auch dass nicht neue herrmann
ist um das melanie brinkmann ist das
wird von wissenschaftlern gefordert weil
wir einfach versuchen in den betrieben
wo nicht ein einziger ansteckung sword
ist aber wohl auch an wichtigen
stationen ist die situation im griff zu
bekommen das hat nichts damit zu tun
also wie gearbeitet wird das dann aus
dem land nichts mit allgemeiner
arbeitsmarktpolitik zu tun und ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass sage ich
ausschließlich aus der perspektive eines
epidemiologen das hat nichts mit
parteipolitik zu tun das wird auch von
sehr vielen wissenschaftlern also
vorgetragen die mit der spd nichts am
hut haben
herr blume wird die gesetzliche
testpflicht für unternehmen kommt also
ich will auch noch eine bemerkung
beantwortet die frage gleichwohl eine
bemerkung machen
krone heute ist ja deutlich gefährlicher
als vor einem jahr
deswegen sollten wir jetzt auch nicht
mehr über sein als im letzten jahr
und da geht es nicht um angst machen
oder gefahren an die wand malen sondern
einmal eine drohende überlastung des
gesundheitssystems abzuwenden
wenn wir uns um andere länder um uns
herum anschauen frankreich österreich
immer noch nicht gedacht haben sie
kommen ist das ist ja keine genannt
er hat gesagt im moment er hat mit der
betrachtung zum tag heute und von mir
ist auch in den kommenden zwei wochen
hatte er recht ich habe mir das zitat
gerade noch mal angeschaut aber es geht
doch darum zu verhindern dass wir in
vier wochen dann an der sit in der
situation sind in der heute viele
krankenhäuser in frankreich inzwischen
sind und deswegen das ist ja das
problematische bei der krone bekämpfung
man muss immer vier wochen weiter denken
denn die fälle die in die
intensivstation kommen die haben sich
schon vor zwei drei wochen angesteckt
und vor dem hintergrund macht es im
moment die beurteilung und auch das
weitere vorgehen so problematisch also
deswegen der kurs von vorsicht und
umsicht gerade in der jetzigen phase ist
der richtige
keine experimente sondern schauen dass
wir mit konsequenten maßnahmen nicht so
schnell wie möglich diese dritte welle
jetzt brechen was ist mit dem mit der
test pflicht für unternehmen sind sie
dafür soll das gesetzlich kommen und was
ist mit der home office pflicht also der
vorteil ist ja dass heute die tests
allgegenwärtig verfügbar sind
man kann die apotheke holen man kann sie
im supermarkt holen und es ist auch
meines erachtens für unternehmen heute
zu gut war zu sagen wie organisieren das
für unseren betrieb ich im war ein ganz
vielen unternehmen die sagen wir machen
das zum teil schon seit vielen wochen
weil wir selbst für unsere mitarbeiter
dieser extra portion sicherheit im
wollen
ich glaube es braucht keine deswegen
nicht zwingend eine gesetzliche pflicht
dazu aber nochmal den eindringlichen
appell in jedem bereich wo menschen
zusammenkommen
auf das thema testen und zwar zwingend
zu setzen
vor stark watzinger was halten sie von
einer gesetzlichen testpflicht für
unternehmen gerne nochmals zu haben laut
aber sagen ich möchte noch mal eins
richtig stellen
fakt ist dass in vielen ins zentrum
man hat dienst schon hochgezogen die
infrastruktur erstellt aber man hat sich
nicht so viele gedanken gemacht wie
machen wir die terminvergabe und gesehen
dass teilweise doppelt termine vergeben
werden und ähnliches und dass dann wenn
abends noch impfstoff übrig ist es
schwierig ist denn im stock noch zu
kämpfen dann müssen pragmatisch vorgehen
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass die
menschen über sich hinaus gegangen sind
tolles geleistet haben
im gesundheitssystem und in vielen
bereichen dieser gesellschaft also das
möchte ich noch einmal richtig stellen
ich glaube dass wir über verschärfende
maßnahmen dann reden müssen denn wir mal
gewonnen haben das was das letzte mal
geschlossen wurde
auch umzusetzen wir haben die tests zwar
jetzt eine test strategie auf dem papier
aber ich sehe es doch in meinem
bundesland in hessen in den schulen gibt
es noch nicht flächendeckend ist also
wir müssen doch erstmal das umsetzen die
milderen mitteln der pandemie bekämpfen
wirklich umgesetzt
hier haben wir ein umsetzungsproblem
kein erkenntnisproblem und dann reden
wir über verschärfungen und der staat
muss eben auch mit gutem vorbild
vorangehen also wenn man mal in den
ministerien anfangen würde eine
testpflicht sich selbst zu geben mir das
schon mal ein erster schritt wenn man
auch den schutz der polizisten und der
menschen in pflegeheime und in den
krankenhäusern dann noch mal sehr ernst
nehmen würde dann wäre das auch ein
vorbild also bevor wir jetzt mit neuen
pflichten kommen müssen wir doch erst
mal das umsetzen was wir uns selbst
strategien gegeben haben nämlich die
infektionskette zu unterbrechen das ist
ja unsere aufgabe und das schaffen wir
durch inseln da haben wir ja schon
darüber gesprochen und durch testen und
das testen ist ehrlich gesagt noch nicht
richtig angelaufen
neben dem impfen und testen und der
frage was in den betrieben den nächsten
wochen passiert wird insbesondere ein
thema immer wieder angesprochen und das
sind die ausgangssperren in einzelnen
ländern einzelnen bundesländern gibt es
sie bereits auch in deutschland aber die
initiative auch von armin laschet heute
gegen in die richtung zu sagen wir
brauchen diese deutschlandweit wir haben
uns einmal umgehört was die menschen
über ausgangssperren in deutschland
denken
seit freitag gelten in berlin neue
ausgangs beschränkungen menschen dürfen
sich nachts zwischen 21 und 5 uhr nur
noch alleine oder zu zweit im freien
aufhalten noch strengere regeln gelten
in hamburg wer sich hier ohne triftigen
grund nach 21 uhr draußen aufhält muss
zahlen denn seit karfreitag darf man die
wohnung ohne triftigen grund nicht mehr
verlassen
die strengen maßnahmen greifen die
reeperbahn menschenleer
was vor tagen noch unvorstellbar schien
kann bald sogar für ganz deutschland
geld
vor allem wenn es nach der kanzlerin und
dem team vor sich geht
doch was hält man in berlin von den
neuen ausgangs beschränkungen
also macht keinen unterschied ist nötig
und ich halte mich ohnehin dran
also ja ich will dass meine wohnung kaum
ich war jetzt nur in der kirche las dass
der größte schwachsinn denn es gibt weil
genau an derzeit sind so wenig leute
unterwegs das ist eigentlich also der
abstand wird eingehalten und alles außer
natürlich wenn irgendwo partys
veranstaltet werden machen wir also
viele partys
diese uhrzeit nach 21 uhr okay ich bin
schon in diesem alter das war auch nicht
was mich deswegen für mich ist das in
ordnung also kleine beschränkung oder
irgendwas sinnvolle die agrana aber
nicht so dass kalter kaffee findet es
hilft leider nichts anderes es gibt zu
viele unvernünftige und zu viele dumme
leute die leider sage ich mal dem gros
der gesellschaft sehr großen schaden
zufügen herr lauter waren sehr geteiltes
bild was die ausgangssperren angeht
auffällig gerade jüngere leute sagen
dass es schwachsinn was bringen die
ausgangssperren aus ihrer sicht wirklich
und vor allem wenn man sich anschaut
können die wirklich kontrolliert werden
hast du nicht was sie bringen das die
beste studie die dazu bisher gebracht
worden ist die studie der oxford
universität die quasi den wert von
ausgangssperren im rahmen der zweiten
welle systematisch insgesamt 117
regionen ausgewertet hat und die diese
studie kommt auch einen erwehren dass
susanne l wehrt senkung von ungefähr 15
13 bis 16 prozent
das ist in der situation in der wir
jetzt sind wäre das genau das was wir
noch benötigen würden um unter die 1 zu
kommen das ist eine sehr große sehr
methodisch an während frage macht ich
studiert und entspricht kleineren
studien die man vorher gemacht hat das
also kein komplett neues ergebnis aber
sehr robust und wer auf deutschland
übertragbar weil das sozusagen eine
fraktion befasst wo man schon viele
andere maßnahmen hat somit erstmal würde
ja jetzt daran er wert von ungefähr 1,2
nach irgendwie man misst und wir würden
die damit wahrscheinlich in den bereich
bekommen erklären sie uns noch mal aus
ihrer sicht als zum beispiel in paris
metropole gibt es ausgangssperren schon
lange und da erlebt man massiv hohe
inzidenz werte teilweise also da scheint
zum beispiel eine ausgangssperre nicht
zu wirken
na ja die situation in paris jahr auch
so eine situation wo man in einigen
besonders betroffenen regionen das
gemacht an den anderen wieder auch nicht
und dann auch so was man hier
ausgewertet hat was bringt das wenn man
das einmal in der gesamten region nach
oder landesweit und das ist entscheidend
und lassen sie mich folgendes
beschreiben
also es kann tatsächlich sein dass man
selbst mit einer ausgangssperre den also
die pandemie mit mehr als 17 in der
dritten werde nicht ausreichend bekämpft
das ganze also was soll man da noch was
geht denn darüber hinaus also eines
verliere ich den faden so ich bin nicht
ich kann mich nicht so lange dann
konzentrieren um nicht den faden zu
verlieren weil diese sonst werden die
genau den orient mutter welche aber
lasse mich nur folge sagen es ist noch
nie gelungen andere sommer welle mit
mehr als 17 zu stoppen ohne dass man
nicht auch zusätzlich ausgangssperren
darin gehabt hätte so mit
ausgangssperren sind ein notwendiger
bestandteil bisher gewesen ist noch nie
ohne gegangen das ist noch gar nichts
gibt kein beispiel wo man eine welle mit
b17 noch die alte variante die vegan
haben die wahl oft brecht war ohne
ausgangssperren also in der ersten welle
oder und die ausgangs also variante ist
nicht so stark die war nicht so
ansteckend aber also ohne
ausgangssperren ist es noch nie gelohnt
und was darüber hinaus geht um ihre
frage zu beantworten das wird zum
beispiel dann also diese testpflicht und
die hof ob sie zusätzlich in den
betrieben vertreten und eben also das
doppelte testen das daher weil wir das
paket worum es hier geht
neben testpflicht in schulen und in
betriebenen home office moratorium für
also lockerungen und ausgangssperren ab
20 uhr kann macht das übrigens nicht
sieben prozent der kontakt aus sondern
zwölf anhalt der kontakt auf der
grundlage der auswertungen der
humboldt-universität und es ist darüber
hinaus auch noch so diese 12 100 prozent
sind oft besonders gefährlicher kontakte
war das sehr häufig und takte im
innenraum sind wo leute sich ungeschützt
dann quasi im sozialen treffen vor
schimke wenn sie das hören viele zahlen
viele studien die karl lauterbach dort
zitiert der wirklich immer bis tief in
die nacht glaube ich sich diese studien
anschaut und auswerte teilweise voll
stimmte aber wenn man sich anschaut wie
die stimmung in deutschland ist da hat
man nicht das gefühl dass die deutschen
oder dass vor allem jüngere deutsche
dazu bereit sind ausgangssperren einfach
so hinzunehmen oder wie sehen sie das
ja also es wirkt ein bisschen
lebensfremd
wenn ihr politischer seite argumentieren
mit studien und sagen wir sparen hier so
und so viel prozent ich meine wenn das
irgendwas bringen würde und wenn die
menschen merken würden dass die
einschränkungen die wir vornehmen
tatsächlich auch einen mehrwert haben
und man am ende die dazu mehr freiheiten
kommt dann mache ich mir um die
akzeptanz unserer corona politik gar
keine gedanken aber was wir eben seit
langem erleben ist ein auf und zu ein
auf und zu spekulieren ein schuld
zuschieben der unternehmer ist schuld
die familie ist schuld und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt dies dass jenes tun und
das ist eben in der tat etwas was die
leute zum wahnsinn treibt und die machen
sowieso was sie wollen also ihr könnt
also wir können ausgangs beschränkungen
verhängen die wir wollen die treffen
sich trotzdem und die menschen in
deutschland lassen sich nicht
vorschreiben ob sie ihre eltern treffen
und ich wäre froh wenn wir das in der
etablierten politik mal verstehen würden
herr blume zunächst aber hier geht es
nicht um schuldzuweisungen also niemand
gibt er ich habe zum beispiel genau wie
herr blume wir geben die man eigentlich
schon
also wir sind nicht die sage nicht die
unternehmer sind schuld ich sage nicht
die menschen die feiern wollen sind
schuld es geht nicht um schuld es geht
nur darum dass wir versuchen gemeinsam
ohne schuldzuweisung aus der burg
auslese auszukommen und sagt ich hab
natürlich nur den 31
niemand von uns wieder blumen doch es
dann auch erleichtert noch eine chance
wir haben nicht mit schon gesprochen und
der zweite punkt ist der also mit der
einstellung dass sie sagen die leute tun
ja sowieso was sie wollen bräuchten wir
gar nichts mehr zu machen dann wäre es
hoffnungslos gott sei dank ist das
falsch gott sei dank haben sie damit
unrecht die allermeisten menschen in
deutschland sind vernünftig und haben
die regeln der wir die gut erklärt haben
gemacht und jetzt sind ja auch zwei
drittel der menschen in deutschland der
meinung dass wir wieder eine art burgen
lockdown um die begrifflichkeit von
ihrer klasse tier zufrieden dass wir das
auch benötigen die leute wollen dass wir
vernünftig sind erlaubt einfach
natürlich sind die menschen wenn ich das
sagen da für uns natürlich sind die
menschen vernünftig und die meisten
halten sich auch daran so und deswegen
ist die frage warum es eben solcher
weitreichende einschränkender maßnahmen
bedarf damit trägt man zum stimmungsbild
in diesem land nicht weiter dazu sagen
gerade absolut recht die meisten
menschen sind werden ihrer verantwortung
wirklich gerecht und deswegen alle in
kollektivhaftung zu nehmen mit einem
flächen welchen flächen deckenden
nächtlichen ausgangssperre das wäre also
absolut unverhältnismäßig und ich glaube
die bundesregierung muss nicht mal ihre
eigene bilanz ansehen was sie geleistet
hat und dem die die menschen
verantwortung vor ort übernommen haben
und deswegen sollten wir den menschen
auch ein stückweit jetzt zu trauern und
handlungen wie wir sind ja nicht sehr
gut dass sie eine verantwortung haben
und den respekt gegenüber der gesundheit
des andreas kunde dorf wir trauen den
mädchen fehlt zu aber wenn es doch so
ist wie uns sammer die studien
tatsächlich zeigen dass es ohne eine
abendliche ausgangs beschränkung schwert
das ist ja nicht geht das können doch
die männchen nicht für dede die mädchen
müssen sie auch das was wir sagen
verlassen können und wenn wir sagen es
tut uns leid das müssen wir jetzt mal
zwei bis drei wochen nach weil es ohne
diese maßnahme nie geklappt hat und weil
wir wichtige studien haben zum beispiel
von der oxford
aber nicht nur von dort dass uns das
hilft dann übernehme ich die
verantwortung und erkläre dass je nach
voran das hat das ist fahrlässig und ich
kann doch jetzt den leuten nicht
überlassen dass sie sich jetzt selbst
überlegen was ist dann war es nicht
gewohnt von uns eine klare ansage
herr blume frau schimpft kritisiert dass
die menschen dass die politik die
menschen teilweise nicht mehr versteht
und sozusagen über studien argumentiert
aber wenig bei den menschen ist treiben
sie die leute in den wahnsinn wenn ich
glaube das gegenteil ist der fall es
wird in manchen diskussionsrunden
systematisch die kollektive intelligenz
in der bevölkerung unterschätzt und auch
das sicherheitsempfinden uhr das
sicherheitsbedürfnis in der bevölkerung
ich sage ganz deutlich effektiver corona
bekämpfung die kann man nicht nach
stimmungslage machen weil man
möglicherweise auch ein verzerrtes
stimmungsbild jeden tag präsentiert
bekommt es gibt und zwar über monate
hinweg sehr stabil eine übergroße
mehrheit in deutschland die die
ergriffenen maßnahmen für angemessen
halten oder die sich sogar noch mehr
wünschen an maßnahmen nämlich dinge die
wirklich wirken und die konsequenz sind
und ich glaube das entscheidende ist und
das ist vielleicht der eigentliche punkt
der schwäche das entscheidend ist dass
wir immer wieder kursabweichungen hatten
wenn es eine klare ansage gibt und dann
auch ein klarer kurs von allen verfolgt
wird und ihnen mit ländern auch
umgesetzt wird dann versteht die
bevölkerung was sache ist und dann habe
ich immer erlebt das ist auch eine sehr
hohe bereitschaft gibt sich an diese
dinge zu halten
ich kann dafür münchen reden münchen
liegt bekanntermaßen in bayern
und es gibt hier seit vielen monaten die
ausgangs beschränkungen in den hotspots
und es hat dazu beigetragen dass in der
millionenstadt münchen die zahlen
deutlich nach unten gekommen waren war
deutlich weiter sind meisten anderen
großstädten in deutschland jetzt in den
letzten wochen im allgemeinen trend
wieder gestiegen und jetzt bei über 100
greift dann auch wieder die ausgangs
beschränkung nicht sage hier in diesen
kreis
ich halte das auch für nötig die es in
den letzten tagen wieder viele bilder
zugeschickt worden wenn es draußen
wärmer ist wo menschen draußen
dicht an dicht stehen und dann plötzlich
wenn alkohol im spiel ist dann
vielleicht auch die ganzen guten aha
regel und alles was wollen sie die
jungen schreiben blume wie lange wollen
sie jugendliche noch ein sprecher es ist
doch völlig normal dass jugendliche
nachmittags in den park gehen oder
abenteurer in den park gehen
wir reden nicht von nachmittag sondern
wir reden von nächtens und wir reden
davon dass plötzlich das was wir sonst
überall versuchen umzusetzen
dass das dann um diese uhrzeit dann
plötzlich nicht mehr geht und darin
liegt die eigentliche gefahr
treiber der infektionen jetzt im moment
sind ja nicht die hochbetagten sondern
sind im die jungen erwachsenen zum teil
auch die jugendlichen und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir bis wir insgesamt
beim impfen und das nehme ich noch mal
das bild der brücke weiters sind dass
wir es jetzt schaffen diese dritte welle
gemeinschaft nicht zu brechen
und nochmal der dringende appell einfach
die notbremsen beschlüsse konsequent
umsetzen nicht sein ganzes land zum
modellversuch werden nicht versuchen
irgendwo schlupflöcher zu finden oder zu
sagen ausgangs beschränkungen bei uns im
land nicht sondern einfach den
instrumentenkoffer anwenden dann werden
wir gemeinschaftlich in deutschland viel
schneller wieder in den beherrschbaren
bereich kommen sie haben gerade über die
jugendlichen gesprochen großes thema für
viele dieser jugendlichen auch ihre
eltern und jüngeren kinder ist die frage
wann können sie endlich wieder in die
schule
denn bei vielen ist der
präsenzunterricht noch gar nicht
zurückgekehrt und bei anderen die
mittlerweile wieder in der schule sind
heißt es jetzt von
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck
der präsenzunterricht hängt am seidenen
faden
herr lauterbach gehen sie davon aus dass
die schulen mit diesem sogenannten
brücken lockdown den herr laschet will
oder bundes lockdown dann komplett
wieder geschlossen werden und nur noch
notfallbetreuung eingeführt wird
nein das glaube ich nicht also die ich
bitte um verständnis dass ich erneut mit
der studienlage hier operieren muss aber
ich glaube dass es ihm ja auch einkommen
die bürger verlangen die auch von uns
dass wir klar sagen was wird und was
wird nicht und hier kann man sagen die
schuldenlage zeigt ganz klar wenn man
die kombination nach wechsel unterricht
plus zweimal pro woche die kinder zu
testen
dann kann man die schulen auch also
jederzeit an der dritten werde sich
beteiligen
das ist keine frage wir müssen wir nicht
in den schul lockdown zurück und das ist
vorbereitet ich soweit ich informiert
bin ich bin ja mit vielen länder
kollegen noch in austausch ist
tatsächlich auch die zeit genutzt worden
um anti gen test zu beschaffen weil es
solche strategie müsste umsetzbar sein
womit also wechsel unterrichtet zwei mal
testen und die schulen können offen
bleiben
frau schimke gehen sie davon aus dass es
genügend tests gibt das dann diese zwei
mal pro woche zur regelung stattfinden
kann und es gab heute eine forderung der
lehrergewerkschaft die gesagt haben
vielleicht müssen wir am ende des jahres
komplett auf prüfung verzichten weil die
schüler einfach zu wenig in der schule
waren ja also das glaube ich erst wenn
es soweit ist herrn zweimal in unseren
schulen tatsächlich auch die tests zur
verfügung stehen ich kann nur sagen ich
habe selbst versucht bei uns hier vor
ort kürzlich corona tests zu erwerben es
war nicht möglich die apotheke hatte
kein ich bin dann woanders sind alles
gut aber es zeigt natürlich dass wir
schon auch ein logistisches problem
haben also tests auch in größenordnungen
zu liefern kinder sind für mich das a
und o bildung genauso hat vorrang vor
allem anderen und deswegen würde ich
hier höchste politische priorität darauf
setzen kindern diese bildung zu
ermöglichen
auf jeden fall ja so und was die
prüfungen anbelangt das ist natürlich
ein armutszeugnis also nach einem jahr
ohne zu sagen man geht jetzt aus dem
abitur ohne prüfung heraus so was darf
nicht sein
herr blume wie ist ihre meinung ohne
prüfung am ende des jahres ist das
vorstellbar also das ist nicht unser weg
in bayern jedenfalls sondern wir
versuchen dass dieses schuljahr bei
allem unbestreitbaren schwierigkeiten
trotzdem noch ein wertvolles eine
halbwegs reguläre schuljahr bleiben kann
es wird kein normales schuljahr sein und
das ist besonders für die
abschlussklassen natürlich entscheidend
da darf den schülerinnen und schülern
aus der situation kein nachteil
erwachsen und deswegen erlebe ich dass
die schulen damit
sehr flexibel aber auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll umgehen die
möglichkeiten zu nutzen die
prüfungsphasen sind verschoben worden
die anzahl der schulaufgaben ist nicht
lassen reduziert worden
also es ist keine schule mehr heute da
die sagt wir müssen jetzt einfach noten
machen wenn die kinder mal eine woche in
der schule sind damit wir ein paar noten
am ende zusammen willkommen sondern ich
sehe dass da eigentlich alle sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit umgehen
vielleicht noch ein wort zum testen
ich sehe inzwischen nicht mehr das
hauptproblem dass die tests an den
schulen nicht gäbe sondern ich sehe die
schwierigkeit dass die test bereitschaft
mitunter der zu gering ausgeprägt ist
wenn wir test quoten haben von etwas
mehr als zehn prozent bei den schülern
und mir berichtet wird aus schulen dass
die eltern dort die einstimmung
verweigern
dass die tests vorgenommen werden weil
irgendwelche horror nachrichten in
irgendwelchen whatsapp gruppen kursieren
was mit den tests alles passieren kann
dann besorgt mich dass weil testen
jenseits des impfens das einzig wirklich
starke instrument ist was uns etwas mehr
sicherheit im alltag geben kann mehr
sicherheit im alltag großes thema
stichwort impfen heute die frage wann
vollständig geimpfte wieder reisen
dürfen und da gab es heute eine große
schlagzeile in der bild am sonntag zum
thema was hier einsparen gesagt hat und
das lka gesagt hat nämlich wer
vollständig geimpft ist ist de facto
nicht mehr infektionsgefährdet also
nicht mehr andere und dazu haben wir uns
auf der straße umgehört
geimpfte dürfen frei reisen so
verspricht es gesundheitsminister jens
spahn in der bild am sonntag von diesem
osterwochenende ist das gerecht oder
nicht wir haben uns mal in berlin
umgehört
wir sind keine zweiklassengesellschaft
und es muss für jeden dieselben rechte
gelten das ist schön wieder verkehrt ich
war acht wochen dort vor ort dann ist
ganz anders hat es daher sparen ganz
anders gesagt das ist wahrscheinlich
jede woche eine neue meinung dann kommen
ja nicht klar aber ich bin und ich will
das so eigentlich möchte ich auch gerne
verweisen was ich sagen versagen der
politiker dass du das mit dem impf nicht
auf die reihe kriegen müssen die bürger
aus waren weiters ist das nicht frau
stark watzinger die menschen auf der
straße er wütend darüber sagen herr
spahn hat vor ein paar monaten noch was
anderes gesagt ein anderer sagte ich bin
nicht geimpft und lauft reisen dürfen
was halten sie von dem vorstoß des
bundesgesundheitsministers ganz
persönlich gibt es mir natürlich auch
ein stich weil ich bin einer der letzten
gruppen zu recht die geimpft werden und
mich heißt das natürlich auch das dann
manche einschränkungen auch gelten diese
dienste nicht mehr gelten
aber es ist nun mal so also da kann man
leider jetzt nicht mit neid argumentiert
es ist längst nicht leider so ist es gut
so
das einheits rechte keine privilegien
sind und sie dürfen nur eingeschränkt
werden wenn für mich oder für andere
einiges haus geht und wenn das nicht
mehr der fall ist dann muss ich auch die
freiheitsrechte darf ich sie nicht
einschränken und insofern sehe ich das
eigentlich verfassungsmäßig als geboten
an und deswegen noch mal wir müssen halt
schauen dass möglichst viele menschen
wieder ohne einschränkungen sich bewegen
können deswegen ist er weg daraus dass
impfen und nicht das verbieten von
freiheitsrechten bei menschen geimpft
sind
schimke wenn das so ist warum gilt das
dann nicht sofort
also ich glaube den wissen da vielleicht
mit einem missverständnis mal aufräumen
weil wenn ich richtig informiert bin hat
der gesundheitsminister gesagt das
einkaufen zum friseur gehen und reisen
dann auch ohne test möglich ist man kann
diese dinge weiterhin tun dann müsste
sich als nicht geimpfter nur testen
lassen
am grundsatz her glaube ich ist
dieses thema ausgesprochen sensibel zu
behandeln wir führen seit monaten eine
diskussion in deutschland um eine
sogenannte impfpflicht und sagen immer
wieder auch als bundestag das wird es
nicht geben und deswegen sollten wir
tunlichst vermeiden
diese argumente zu befeuern ja durch
durch solche durch solche aussagen aber
ziel muss sein aus der pandemie
rauszukommen das heißt irgendwann den
menschen auch wieder vor augen zu halten
ist trifft dieser normalität ein und es
muss sich auch nicht jeder impfen lassen
in deutschland das ist freiwillig und
das muss auch so bleiben das halte ich
für sehr wichtig herr lauterbach müssen
vollständig geimpft künftig dann noch
maske tragen und wenn ja warum
eigentlich
ja ist eine sehr gute frage zunächst
sondern wir wissen was wir verbrochen
auch nicht wussten dass diejenigen die
doch zweimal gefahren sind das die sich
nur noch selten ansteckend und werden
sie sich einstecken erkannten sie ja
schon gleich gar nicht nur leicht und
sind wahrscheinlich dann nicht
ansteckend so mittel so sind die
regelungen ich war ersparen jetzt was
wir vorgeschlagen hat dass man die
kämpften wie mit antigenen test getestet
bewahren wird das geht in die richtige
richtung das finde ich daher auch
richtig studienlage ist noch nicht so
fest aber das wird sich in den nächsten
wochen setzt sich das er war seine
touren dann kamera zu beschließen
warum nicht ab bitte warum nicht ab
sofort warum wird das nicht ab sofort ja
weil es eben noch erstens sehr
vorläufige daten was wir wissen zum
beispiel nicht ob das auch für den
impfstoff von johnson johnson gehen
naja jetzt ist das zu uns kommt wir
wissen noch nicht genau als so ab
welcher woche dass beiersdorf nach der
zweiten informiert wissen es nicht genau
wir wissen es auch nicht ob es geht wenn
wir beispielsweise mehr fälle mit der
südafrikanischen variante haben dann
wird es halt das ist schon nicht mehr
geht und es wird also zum teil dann auch
geforscht aber das geht tatsächlich von
der derzeitigen studienlage in die
richtung die ersparen zurecht
ausgewiesen hat jetzt so zu ihrer frage
mit den masken
na ja es kann natürlich nicht also sage
mal bei jeder gelegenheit da ebenfalls
was wo gezahlt wird und somit die
einschränkungen müssen ja immer
bis mäßig sein das risiko dass man sich
infiziert nach der impfung und dann
andere noch ansteckt ist ein relativ
geringes risiko aber dass masken tragen
und das abstandhalten ist ja auch eine
relativ geringe einschränkungen
somit würde ich es wie folgt betrachten
das tatsächlich also viele der dinge die
man mit einem antigen test machen kann
dass man die auch als gäste ohne anti
gentest machen kann
das ist richtig aber der verzicht auf
also abstand und masken tragen der sorte
aus war sich erst erwogen werden wenn
wir alle durch diese krise durch sind
herr blume brauchen wir jetzt ganz
schnell einen nationalen internationalen
eu-weiten weltweiten impfpass dass wir
dinge auch wieder möglich machen können
für diejenigen die geimpft sind und für
alle anderen mit einem entsprechenden
test dieser europaweiten passt er ist ja
in umsetzung der ist auch gut und
sinnvoll weil zu der normalität in
europa nach corinna ja hoffentlich auch
wieder das beschwerdefreie reisen durch
europa und darüber hinaus gehören kann
ich glaube die perspektive die hier
aufgezeigt wird ist schon die richtige
aber sie kommt eigentlich erst voll dann
zum tragen wenn auch wirklich das
impfangebot für alle da ist und nicht
nur für teilgruppen der gesellschaft und
meine persönliche einschätzung ist
manche der sogenannten a haarige
lauterbach hat ja auch gerade angedeutet
die werden uns wahrscheinlich noch ein
gutes stück länger verfolgen
man kann es ja auch an ländern in asien
beobachten wo maske tragen sehr viel
mehr selbstverständlichkeit in sonstigen
zeiten grippewelle oder was auch immer
ist als das bei uns der fall war
und solange wir nicht absolute
sicherheit haben wie impfstoffe wirken
welche varianten es gibt wie sich die
verhalten
solange glaube ich ist man gut beraten
mit den allgemeinen regeln
weiterzufahren
aber so wie sie einsparen angedeutet hat
dass sowohl der negative tests wie auch
der immunitätsausschuss durch schimpfen
das ist irgendwo äquivalent ist ich
glaube eine perspektive ist also in
jedem fall der richtige weg aber
verstehen sie dann wenn sie sagen es
müssen erst mehr menschen geimpft sein
den zeitpunkt des vorstoßes
das ist ja ein tag wo wir einerseits
überhaupt mögliche freiheiten für
geimpfte sprechen und dann darüber dass
wir den härteren lockdown brauchen also
war das jetzt das falsche timing punkt
bundesgesundheitsminister ich glaube das
ist jetzt heute nicht der tag um auch an
der stelle wieder irgendwelche
schulnoten zu verteilen ist auch gar
nicht notwendig ich habe vorhin schon
gesagt wir bekommen jetzt im zweiten
quartal über 70 millionen impfdosen nach
deutschland und nach diesem zweiten
quartal dann über solche dinge zu reden
das glaube ich schon notwendig und wir
müssen uns aus deutschland solche
diskussionen dann dauernd dann auch
gerne mal etwas länger
deswegen darüber jetzt gedanken zu
machen wie es dann sein wird halten
ebenfalls für richtig wenn wir das
zweite quartal über das dritte quartal
sprechen darüber dass dann mehr menschen
geimpft sind vielleicht die menschen
tatsächlich sommerurlaub noch machen
können obwohl es in anderen ländern
sicher besser funktionieren wird wie zum
beispiel den usa oder großbritannien
dann sprechen wir auch über die
bundestagswahl im herbst und ja da hat
es frau schimpft neue entwicklungen
gegeben was eine mögliche
kanzlerkandidatur angeht nämlich hat
markus söder der csu-chef heute in der
bild am sonntag gesagt dass er möchte
dass die kanzlerin der eine rolle spielt
können sie sich die kanzlerin als
schlichterin davor stellen zwischen
armin laschet und markus söder und wann
und wer sollte entscheiden wer für die
union antritt
also wir schätzen natürlich den rat
unserer bundeskanzlerin sehr als
parteienfamilie allerdings glaube ich
schon dass nach 16 jahren angela merkel
beweisen sollten dass wir eigene
lösungen finden und vor allen dingen
auch die zeit nach ihrer ära auch
bestreiten
und deswegen glaube ich ist es
angebracht dass die beiden herren sowie
ist nun schon sehr sehr lange
angekündigt ist sich darauf verständigen
wer es macht
ich finde es ist auch langsam an der
zeit dass wir das tun die menschen
warten auf antworten da draußen
vereinigung auf inhaltliche antworten
und auch auf personelle antworten ganz
klare gut kanzlerkandidat aber auch wer
gehört zu dem team der damit läuft ja
wir sind eine mannschaft und so sollten
wir auch auftreten und das ist das was
mich eigentlich vornehmlich interessiert
wenn sie die umfragen jetzt sehen markus
söder fast uneinholbar vorn vor armin
laschet
sollte sie das machen na ja also wir
haben alle so viele erfahrungen dass wir
wissen dass in einem bundestagswahlkampf
immer noch eine ganze ganze menge
passieren kann und diese umfragen sind
eine momentaufnahme
mir ist es fast gleich wer es macht im
hauptsache derjenige weiß die themen für
die sie sagen sie seien fast gleich aber
für wen sind sie denn persönlich
also ich glaube dass beide die richtigen
fähigkeiten haben dafür ist sind zwei
völlig unterschiedliche typen natürlich
kann ich nicht von der hand weisen dass
markus söder hier bei uns auch in den
neuen bundesländern sehr gut ankommt ja
aber ich will auch armin laschet diese
fähigkeiten in keiner weise absprechen
im gegenteil er hat sie ja nordrhein
westfalen unter beweis gestellt ich wäre
noch etwas davon mal zu sehen aber gehen
sie davon aus dass markus söder zur
verfügung stünde
naja also danach das muss man ja wohl
annehmen im moment also wenn man sich
das schauspiel anschaut aber da bin ich
auch nur betrachter vom spielfeldrand
herren seemann davos ist hier leider
enttäuschen habe ich kein expertenwissen
expertenwissen hat ganz sicher markus
blume der csu-generalsekretär blume was
war das heute in der bild am sonntag
also die kanzlerin soll jetzt mit
mission bedeutet dass am ende
man trifft sich zu dritt zum frühstück
und sagt okay der macht nein das heißt
eines was ganz klar ist dass wir ja
nicht aus der opposition heraus in
diesen bundestagswahlkampf gehen mit
völlig anderen ideen konzepten mit einem
bruch der letzten erfolgreichen 16 jahre
sondern dass wir versuchen natürlich aus
16 erfolgreichen regierungsjahren heraus
etwas neues zu beginnen
das ist bisher in der bundesrepublik
noch nie
gelungen und wir als union wir wollen
das zeigen und zwar cdu und csu
gemeinsam
ich bin auch nach wie vor sehr überzeugt
dass das gelingen kann
es wird im team gelingen da gehören die
beiden parteivorsitzenden dazu und das
gehört natürlich auch diejenige dazu die
bis zum wahltag diese regierung in
deutschland führt aber aber welche rolle
soll jetzt die kanzlerin konkret spielen
das habe ich noch nicht verstanden also
dass sie vielleicht im wahlkampf
auftritt ja aber was welche konkrete
rolle sie spielen jetzt bei der findung
und ist kanzlerkandidat also
entscheidend ist doch der teamgedanke
und jetzt leben sie noch heute werden
soll ich da nein ich gebe ihm eine
antwort und die heißt das in dieser zeit
bis zum 26
september das sind noch sechs lange
monate in diesen monaten da hoffen wir
gemeinsam dass wir die korona pandemie
überwinden
da kommt es auch gutes regierungshandeln
an da kommt es darauf an dass man
wirklich gemeinschaftlich unterwegs ist
dass man denselben kurs mitträgt aber
haben sich gefragt kannst den kanzler
hab ich aber sagen dass man das dass man
nicht die dinge die man heute schon tun
kann erst auf einen tag nach der wahl
verlegt sondern das was im grunde sofort
notwendig ist dann auch tatsächlich
sofort umsetzt und dazu braucht die
bundesregierung dazu braucht die
bundeskanzlerin dazu sind wir auch
dankbar dass wir sie haben also die
kanzlerin hat ja mehrfach gesagt sie
will sich raushalten aus dem
parteiinternen wettbewerb und will mit
dieser frage nichts zu tun haben und
jetzt sagt markus söder sie so eine
rolle spielen also was soll sie konkret
machen ist doch ganz klar
bis zum letzten tag gut regieren in
deutschland das ist das was die menschen
von der union erwarten
und gleichzeitig werden wir cdu und csu
gemeinsam zeigen dass wir auch verdammt
viele ideen haben für die jahre danach
denn klar ist die tage wochen monate die
wir jetzt erleben es wird es historisch
gesehen irgendwann wahrscheinlich als
große zäsur eingeordnet die welt nach
corona und nach diesen 16 jahren sie
wird eine andere eine neue sein und
deswegen müssen wir neue antworten geben
nicht mit der vergangenheit brechen aber
deutlich machen auch was ist
dieser neuen zeit ankommt gefällt da wie
auch der cdu schon ganz viel ein
zum thema buckel hat programme natürlich
auch schulungen sowie ihr wahlprogramm
aber mich interessiert immer noch die
frage was da jetzt bei der
kanzlerkandidatur passiert und zwar hat
sich unter anderem alexander dobrindt
heute geäußert und hat gesagt auch die
unionsfraktion soll eine rolle spielen
bei der entscheidung heißt dass
demnächst werden sich alle csu
abgeordnete für markus söder aussprechen
also wir haben bisher noch nicht über
das format gesprochen über das format in
dem die entscheidung dann zwischen den
beiden parteien fällt es war historische
immer so und das war immer wichtig dass
es eine gemeinschaftliche entscheidung
war zunächst mal der beiden
parteivorsitzenden und wir sind jetzt
genau dem zeitfenster was immer genannt
war nämlich zwischen ostern und
pfingsten dass man sich hier miteinander
ins benehmen gesetzt und dann den
parteien und natürlich auch der
bundestagsfraktion einen vorschlag
unterbreitet und ich bin mir sicher
beide werden dabei auch in rechnung
stellen was in ihren parteien in den
fraktionen und auch sonst gedacht wird
und wann wird jetzt markus söder
erklären dass er antreten möchte weil
wenn er das nicht tut dann wird es doch
armin laschet oder also ich glaube zu
dem verfahren gehört ja auch dass man
nicht im vorfeld irgendwelche
einseitigen erklärungen abgibt auch
armin laschet hat diese erklärungen
bisher nicht abgegeben sondern dass man
sich zusammensetzt und überlegt was ist
das beste fürs land und für die parteien
und diese entscheidung die wird
demnächst kommen und ich bin mir sicher
wir werden auch in diesem kreis dann bei
ihnen hier heraus haben wir darüber
reden wie entscheiden sind der umfragen
letzte frage dazu also umfragen sind auf
der einen seite ist ja gerade schon
gesagt wurden natürlich momentaufnahmen
und ich habe vorhin gesagt ein halbes
jahr im corona zeiten ist eine
unglaublich lange zeit auf der anderen
seite geben sie natürlich schon gewisse
indikation und gewissen trend und
insoweit kann man sich auch nicht
komplett natürlich beiseite wischen hand
armin laschet dieser vorstoß heute
geschadet dass er jetzt andere
ministerpräsidenten schon wieder sagen
wollen sie gar nicht die mpk
ich glaube der beitrag von ihm ist ja
getrieben davon dass er sieht wir müssen
vielleicht doch mehr tun und dieses mehr
tun das ist etwas was wir was auch
markus söder in den letzten wochen sich
eigentlich immer gewünscht hat es hat
ein bisschen an der politischen
konsequenz insgesamt gefehlt und wenn
der beitrag von armin laschet jetzt
einer ist der dazu führt dass auch seine
eigenen parteikollegen sagen jawohl
wenn der bundesvorsitzende der cdu sagt
wir müssen hier mehr tun wir müssen
konsequenter sein
dann wollen wir das gemeinsam auch
machen wenn das dazu einen beitrag
leistet dann war es in jedem fall ein
guter beitrag also der war nicht
konsequent genug aus ihrer sicht die
letzten monate bei krone sie wissen dass
herr ron sondern wir haben vielfach
darüber gesprochen
es gibt keine blaupause es gibt keinen
plan und die ziele ändern sich die
umstände ändern sich im moment sehen wir
es muss noch mehr getan werden um die
dritte welle schneller zu brechen und
insofern war der vorstoß von armin
laschet einer den ich auch so verstanden
habe dass man sich auch an den eignen an
den einen oder anderen eigenen
ministerpräsidenten gerichtet hat
schnell zum abschluss will auch sie mit
in die schlussrunde nehmen wo es um die
kanzlerkandidatur geht frau stark
watzinger mit wem würden sie denn in
einer möglichen neuen regierung am
liebsten koalieren mit markus egger oder
mit armin laschet ja ich wünsche mir ja
auch nicht dass andere parteien in
unsere personalien hineinreden ich
wünsche mir aber einen kanzlerkandidaten
ich erwarte von einem kanzlerkandidaten
nicht als bürgerin dass ich im
stundentakt schlagzeilen gekommen
sondern ich will dass eine konsistente
politik gefahren wird sei es in corona
zeiten aber sei es auch mit den vielen
aufgaben die diese bundesregierung der
nächsten hinterlässt digitalisierung
demographie wirtschaftliche aufschwung
und da kommt aus ergebnis auf an und
nicht auf die lautstärke
herr lauterbach sie sind viel mit der
kanzlerin den kontakt sagen sie immer in
bezug auf corona was haben sie das
gefühl wen würde die kanzlerin aus der
korona perspektive heraus
am liebsten haben wollen markus söder
oder armin asche ich weiß dass nicht das
so und also da waren wir noch nie
geredet
wenn ich es wüsste würde ich so nicht
sagen ein schönes schlusswort herzlichen
dank für den heutigen abend herzlichen
dank an karl lauterbach an markus blume
an bettina stark watzinger und ja damit
geben wir zurück nicht zurück sondern
schauen auf den morgigen tag und da gibt
es natürlich wieder bild live
[Musik]